ein wunderschöner abend erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen minecraft hätte
meine lieben front ja ich war es heute
geht's auf jeden fall ab meine lieben
freunde denn wir werden heute in die
bastion gehen was verschiedene grade
generell diese insel hier ist echt schön
und ich würde allerdings sagen dass ich
erst mal kurz schlafen gehen denn so
schön dass sie alles ist mit diesem
abend licht von der sonne ich habe keine
lust auf die monster der mond geht
aufgrund ich bewege mich in mein bett
gehen meine liebe freunde bevor wir in
die hölle gehen haben wir noch ganz kurz
ein paar sachen auf unserer insel zu
erledigen wird aber nicht lange dauern
keine sorge und zwar möchte ich euch
erst mal ganz kurz sagen beziehe ich
mich dafür entschuldigen dass die
gestrige folge ein wenig zu spät kamen
die kamen jetzt um 20.15 oder so online
ich habe euch meine instagram stop ich
dachte du hast mich abgeschossen und
wollte mich ganz kurz dafür
entschuldigen dass die letzte episode
ein bisschen zu spät kam
wenn ihr mir auf instagram folgen ich
hatte dort laserdrucker machen dann
wüsstet ihr dass ich noch ein paar
upload probleme hatte beziehungsweise
länder probleme und deswegen kann ich
das jeden auch nur empfehlen wir bei
instagram zu folgen
ich habe auch ein neues foto hochgeladen
gern icon verlust den cee'd unterwegs
wir müssen sie allerdings erst bei
einigen
das ist nicht so gewohnt wir müssen hier
erst mal einige neue schilder dranhängen
uns war es hier oben noch platz für
einen kommentar von dem lieben kino fan
und zwar der mir gesagt du musst auf
jeden fall den leuchtturm dran schreiben
dem möchtest du noch bauen deswegen hier
oben einmal den leuchtturm dran
platziert und hier oben einmal ganz kurz
den kommentar scharf holen das hat mir
nämlich der liebe frank geschrieben denn
um ein schaf sitzt immer noch hinten in
dem dorffest wie schön das aussieht mit
dem nebel egal ich darf mich nicht
ablenken lassen meine lieben freunde das
kann ich von mir dazu do liste erst mal
streichen
und wie zb das zuvor denn ich will
wirklich wie schön das aus des
verdienten diesem weg haben auf die
andere inseln ich habe noch eine letzte
sache zu tun bevor wir in die hölle
gehen und dementsprechend die bastion
ruine oder ich gehe wieder runter wir
nehmen uns jetzt auf jeden fall die
bücher aus unserer sehr wertvollen kiste
keine hatte er gerade feuerschutz und 3d
das brauchen wir nicht endlich wurde und
in die kommentare geschrieben luca du
kannst doch einfach eines seiner bücher
nehmen und das in den sauber tisch
reinpacken da kannst du mich das einfach
verzaubern und die tatsache ist dass man
dadurch eventuell die unendliche
verzauberung für den boden bekommen
könnte unabhängig das jetzt mal rein wir
haben entladung rückstoß und durchschuss
durch schuss hört sich an wie ein
anderes wort für durchfall also mit dem
buch macht es keinen richtigen sinn ich
könnte allerdings noch mit dem bogen
reinpacken vielleicht haben dass er
jetzt endlich wir haben halt macht drei
stärke 2 und städten komme man steckt
der profi schon halb kaputt ich würde
sagen wir sind fertig für das große ziel
[Musik]
ich werde es versuchen nicht zu tun
meine lieben freunde allerdings kann ich
nicht garantieren denn ich habe den
kommentaren gelesen dass die bastion sru
ihre ein extrem schwieriger ort sein
soll von daher drückt mir die daumen
denn wir bewegen uns zurück indem
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe ordentlich
hier vorne befindet sich auch unser
portal und in der letzten erfolge haben
wir herausgefunden dass sich dort hinten
also wirklich 100 blöcke oder so von
unserem portal entfernt eine bastion
ruine befindet und in so einer bastion
ruine kann man wohl extra
[Musik]
die teile sind ja so stark ich habe
keine ahnung wo sich das kind von diesem
war zu schauen jetzt befindet allerdings
haben wir da oben in der bastion ruine
noch weitere bombers von daher würde ich
sagen wir laufen als einfach mal hin
hier vorne habe ich gerade noch ein
bisschen netter reck abgebaut anderthalb
stacks damit ich einfach wenn ich in der
bastion ruine bin so ein bisschen mich
auch einbauen kann wenn es ein bisschen
brenzlig wird die frage ist jetzt wie
hier rüber kommen da vorne ist zwar eine
sandra die befindet sich allerdings
schon mitten auf dem wasser
deswegen müssen wir hier am besten außen
rum laufen und ich würde sagen das
machen wir jetzt auch einfach mal ich
weiß nicht ob ihr euch mit dem pensions-
ruinen so ein bisschen auseinander
gesetzt habe oder ob ihr wisst was das
sind allerdings habe ich mir dazu ein
bisschen was auf wikipedia durchgelesen
und es ist wirklich extrem heftig denn
diese bastion ruinen sind mit die
stärksten festungen die es überhaupt
gibt den minecraft und das ist gerade
für mich nicht sonderlich krass guten
spieler ziemlich ernüchternd ich bin
gespannt wie oft ich heute sterben werde
oder ob ich überhaupt sterben werde
als auch zu brennen stehe ich noch habe
ich verloren
die last ich werde hier vorne jetzt auf
jeden fall noch mal kurz das quarz
mitnehmen eigentlich könnte ich das ja
auch mit meiner glück spitzhacke abbauen
allerdings doch die habe ich sogar mit
also dass weitere quarz kann ich auf
jeden fall damit abbauen quarz brauchen
wir auch falls ihr euch die ganze zeit
übrigens frage warum ich das überhaupt
nochmal applaus
einerseits für unseren kosten einerseits
brauchen wir das quartz für unseren
leuchtturm war ich dass da eigentlich
ganz schön finde
und wir brauchen das kreuz auch für
etwas was sich in einer der nächsten
folgen macht
möchte und zwar ein strandhaus
[Musik]
aber wo kommt das
häufigster ich habe bisher kein einziges
gold erz abgebaut das heißt die leute in
der bastion sollten mir gegenüber
eigentlich gut gestimmt sein ich hab
halt immer ein bisschen schiss dass
meine shift-taste irgendwie ein bisschen
rum spaß und ich dann irgendwie rein
falle allerdings haben wir die hälfte
schon geschafft lukas mach dir keine
sorgen mach dir keine sorgen vertrauen
in eine tastatur habe vertrauen in einer
tastatur wir sind da lieber nicht
einbauen nicht hier ganz einfach
einlaufen ich werde hier nichts anfassen
das waren noch zeiten ich weiß nicht was
man hier zu erwarten hat und es sieht
auch alles ziemlich kaputt aus da oben
ist gold das sollte ich besser nicht
abbauen
aber hier vorne kann man auf jeden fall
lang ist alles sehr dunkle glaub ich
gerade für euch jedoch liegt das auch
einfach daran hätte er es mir gegenüber
cool
das heißt die anderen sollten eigentlich
mir auch nichts anhaben dürfen
die frage von mir jetzt vorgehen weil
der grund warum ich hier den sünder
[Musik]
mit angriffen warum sind die sauer warum
ist der sauer
warum ist er dort mit der beute
warum sind die noch nicht warum sind
diese orte gab therapie denn jetzt
passiert denn er trank
denn jetzt muss warum sie die
ich möchte noch mit
ich dachte die tun mir nichts wenn ich
nicht aber die nächste folge wird
erstmal insel reparatur sein und zwar
die insel reparatur 2.0 könnt ihr euch
schon mal im kalender eintragen kommt
übermorgen online am montag freue ich
mich mega drauf weil ich eine riesige
notiz aber kommt der nächste direkt aber
wie sieht und ihr sagt mir dass es ihr
schwer
ich baue jetzt auch einfach das gold ab
das ist mir jetzt egal
das ist mir jetzt egal denn jetzt bin
ich im krieg
jetzt kann mir keiner mehr was mir egal
ob jetzt kommt
[Musik]
das gehört einfach dazu zusammenspiel
manchmal verliert man und manchmal
gewinnt die anderen es völlig normal
es liegt in der natur der sache von
daher sollte man da nicht ausrasten
man sollte sich besinnen aus seinen
fehlern lernen warum habe ich nur noch
sieben experience level obwohl ich
vorhin 24 hatte müssen einfach ganz
vorsichtig vorgehen hier liegt noch ein
schild keine ahnung ob das mainz ist das
hätte ich vorher vielleicht auch mal
kurz benutzen können erst gestern ist
eine kiste ich könnte einfach den raum
hier zu bauen und an die kiste rangehen
ich weiß allerdings nicht ob das klappt
ich werde jetzt einfach mal machen wir
haben den ausgeleuchteten raum der ist
fast abgeschirmt lebensweise ich schaue
mir nochmal komplett ab hier und dann
öffne ich jetzt einfach mal die erste
kiste
[Musik]
legal ist das ist schon eine pure
enttäuschung meine taktik ist es jetzt
so langsam wie möglich an die ganze
nummer heranzugehen
ich habe allerdings auch keine ahnung
von wo die leute hier kommen die kommen
ja irgendwie von überall hier waren wir
gerade
ich kann mir dieses blöde ist ich sehe
hier auch nichts aber das ding kann ja
nicht unendlich groß sein kann man hier
oben kommen wir jetzt raus
wo sind wir jetzt hier weit oben wir
schon sind
hier sind ein paar leute da ist auf
jeden fall noch eine menge quarz ich
glaube da werde ich mal eben kurz rüber
gehen er hier ist nur der zombie
villages der hier müsste mich aber
eigentlich angreifen
er macht aber auch nichts
alles gut und ich geb dir mal ein
bisschen gold hier denn jetzt im
gegenzug lassen
[Musik]
ich gebe ihm eine rüstung von mir und
datenlecks gegenleistung gibt dann ja
auch etwas macht er zieht wieder sagen
wenn ich dem kollegen von mir dem pony
schenke dann okay ich würde allerdings
sagen dass wir uns mal wieder hier rein
bewegen
ich weiß zwar nicht wo wir dann hier hin
wollen ich könnte mal hierhin gewartet
auf jeden fall noch einer
die mögen mich auf jeden fall auch nicht
zu sagen du bist auch droht der töten
ist so viele von denen hier gerade das
kann doch nicht sein dass hier noch so
viel von dem schilde überall sehr stark
wie kann er damit so stark sein
mein plan war es eigentlich richtig
bedacht vorzugeben und denen keine
angriffsfläche zu geben so dass ich ganz
entspannt hier mein ding machen kann
aber es hat alles nichts gebracht es hat
alles nichts gebracht da ist meine items
ich weiß nicht ob er noch gegenwert
schild von denen aber es sieht gerade
nicht danach aus ich habe ihnen nichts
getan gar nichts von mir aus habe ich
nie jemanden angegriffen das waren ihm
an odin immer und trotz dessen ja was
ist denn hier los
seine komplette party
ich weiß nicht wo ich hier bin
aber irgendwie sieht das hier aus wie
deren konferenzraum wie viele kisten
hier sind ich nehme mir vorne erstmal
auch das gold mit damit ich zumindest
erstmal weiß wie so ein bisschen
abschätzen kann ob von irgendwo noch
immer
das ganze noch kein match mehr
das kannst du doch nicht allen erzählen
ich packe jetzt einfach hier den ganzen
alten kram es rein bin ich nicht brauche
ich eh nicht mag mag leben nämlich mal
mit eisenwaren ganz viele pfeile die
spektrale feile nehme ich jetzt auch mal
mit keine ahnung was ich damit sollten
die seide knochen blöcke brauche ich
haben ja genug gebratenen
schweinefleisches je nicht sehen läufer
keinen plan was das bringt bahn 2 was
weiß ich habe mir selber machen nämlich
nochmal mit schau dir nochmal einige
sind auch noch eine menge pfeile gold
blog us gold apfel nämlich auch noch mit
was ich denn hier das mal ein bisschen
kartoffeln hier dann kann ich was essen
verbrennung zwei brauche ich erstmal
nicht
wir schauen aber die kisten hier vorne
was wir darin haben und feile eisen
klumpen gold blog antica schrott
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
habe dann können wir uns mit dem antiken
schrotten der beriet barren machen und
wenn der beriet barren können wir sachen
kräften die kratzer sind als diamant
sachen der profiliga ich hoffe dass sie
liegen lassen wird allerdings sagen dass
das eine ziemlich gute ausbeute ist für
diese bastion ruine ich weiß nicht ob
hier noch irgendwo mehr ist ich bin
schon fast zwei stunden habe ich will
die kiste da unten noch haben also die
beiden sachen will ich mir auf jeden
fall noch krallen
ich gehe jetzt auch mal ein bisschen
aggressiver vor und wert das denke ich
einfach jetzt in einem solo durch raub
durch durchlauf werde ich mir das gern
aber ich bin hier und hier ist kein
anderer
also mal reingucken die klumpen nehme
ich mit die captain eigentlich alles was
ich hier mitnehmen kann
ihn erwarten sind wir erstmal egal wir
können immer noch mal wiederkommen ich
brauche mich noch mal kurz herüber und
nehme hier den gold blog mit dann haben
wir dann haben wir wirklich einiges
erreicht in der heutigen episode hier
vorne habe ich die ganze zeit angst zu
sterben
aber ich gehe jetzt auch zurück leute
ich gehe zurück das war's für mich drin
das ist wirklich das ist geisteskrank
kräftig hier gewesen
[Musik]
unter sind wir wieder bei unserem portal
angekommen meine lieben freunde ich
bewege mich dort rein und wir befinden
uns nun endlich wieder in meiner
normalen welt ich bin so froh wieder
hier zu sein meine lieben freunde auch
wenn gerade nacht ist und auch wenn wir
jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder zehn
milliarden kwh übersehen werden es ist
so schön wenn man einfach wieder zu
hause ist aber schaut euch mal an was
wir alles bekommen haben unmengen an
gold das war es einfach drei gold blöcke
das sind drin
ein bisschen reisen diesen antiken
schrott dk es ist das kann mit dem jetzt
machen die heutige wurde minecraft mit
luca dann allerdings auf beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch heute mal
wieder diesel super xxl folge gefallen
hat das gern einen daumen hoch und
verliert über den kanal und wenn ihr
schon abonnent sind dann klicke bitte
gerne auf die glocke sondern verpasst
ihr neuer uploads von mir nicht mein
nächstes video kommt ja wie bereits
gesagt über morgen um 20 uhr am montag
wird die insel reparatur folge 2.0
falls sie ein bisschen später als 20 uhr
kommen sollte dann aktiviert bitte die
glocke oder check bei dienste ab geht
jetzt gerne auf meine install ein neues
fotos mich sehr freuen